- So wait, speaking of
like American treasures.
- Yeah.
- Is it true that The Simpsons was like
kind of how you learned about America?
- Yeah.
I feel like for a lot of people
growing up in England like
there are things I know about
America and American culture,
like by the time I was eight years old
I was like, Bismark is the
capital of North Dakota
and I know that because of The Simpsons.
And I feel like there's a ton of just like
movie stuff and references
to things that I did not understand
when I was watching the show.
- Yeah.
And then I saw those
movies like 10 years later
and I was like, oh, a clock work orange
or like Indiana Jones,
like, oh, that was what that was
and yeah that was a I
think a big introduction
to like all of America.
- It's not far off,
you know, the show.
- I think it's,
- it's not far off.
- I mean, it's like, I think it's a
if you wanted to like just,
if you came to earth tomorrow
and had to quickly educate
somebody about the last 30 years
of American culture,
you could do worse than
doing The Simpsons.
- I'm just saying, I'm just
saying it is a great show,
but I don't know that
it's great to be that,
that's our thing, yes.
- Oh no,
I think that's--
- But I do think it's true.
- You only get, this is the thing
I always say to Americans always,
you only get like the best of British TV.
That's why you all think we're like smart
and sweet and nice
and you see Bakeoff and that's great,
but like, but there's a
world of other British TV
that you don't see.
That's very bad.
- I grew up on Faulty Towers.
- That's exceptional.
- Oh my God.
- That's awesome.
- It's exceptional, yeah
and Are You Being Served,
I don't know if you.
- Also, I loved
Are You Being Served,
- God.
- that is of its time,
but it's great.
- It is amazing.
- Yeah, it's fantastic.
My like that and a show called Allo, Allo,
which is just a bunch
of English people doing
bad French accents the whole time.
- Oh my God, I would love this show.
- You really would.
Yeah.
- Again, it's like,
it was a moment in time,
you couldn't do it now,
but it was very funny.
- I think we could do it now.
Just lean in.
- I don't think
France would be happy.
- It's fun.
I know.
People need to relax.